scientists and health agencies are
trying to understand why monkey pox is
suddenly spreading more widely than ever
before
it's been well uh studied in the african
region we've seen a few cases in europe
over the last five years just in
travelers but this is the first time
we're seeing cases across many countries
at the same time
in people who have not traveled to the
to the endemic regions in africa endemic
in parts of central and west africa in
the past it was generally confined to
isolated cases outside that region now
with evidence of community transmission
via close bodily contact across many
countries they'll be investigating
whether the virus has become more
transmissible
the question is whether it will develop
like previous monkey pox outbreaks we
must take into consideration that the
way the virus spreads could mean it
changed so we must react quickly and
decisively now to contain a global
outbreak
the symptoms are generally mild if
unsightly and often clear up on their
own but there are higher risk groups
among the young and immunocompromised so
the european center for disease
prevention and control is warning member
states to gear up for possible vaccine
distribution using remaining supplies of
the vaccine that helped eradicate
smallpox in the 1980s
beyond concern however no one is
signaling alarm
for the broader population the
likelihood of spread is very low
however the likelihood of further spread
of the virus through close contact for
example during sexual activities among
persons with multiple sexual partners is
considered to be high in a world still
wracked by the covet-19 pandemic
societies have an advanced understanding
of viral spread and protection testing
contact tracing self-isolation and basic
hygiene are household concepts so
containing a disease like monkey pox
should be relatively easy
jonah hull al jazeera